[Applause]
are
happy Thursday everyone
finally finally something worth watching
on CNN
since the great Don Lemon left which
means it's time for Trump versus CNN
Insurrection 2 the rematch
so last night Donald Trump did a town
hall on CNN and it went over as well as
a spelling bee hosted by John fetterman
because how dare you laugh at that
[Applause]
we haven't seen a welcome that warm
since someone came to the view with two
cows and a bag of charcoal
what a great idea have a pro-trump
audience just to make the heads of
what's left of the CNN audience explode
remember the only people who watch CNN
work for CNN or other media so seeing
people applaud for Trump that's worse
than cheering for Jaws to eat more
children
for an hour plus Trump and his debate
opponent I mean Town Hall moderator
Caitlin Collins Tangled he talked and
she under talked
to put in seven ballots a piece
stop you there because because there is
no evidence today Obama took them Nixon
took them Reagan took them one question
can you mind I would like for you to
answer okay it's very simple day that's
why I asked it it's very simple that
you're a nasty person I'll tell you
[Applause]
like When Harry Met Sally
Val Kilmer had an easy easier time
speaking in the Top Gun sequel
he would have laughed Trump was in front
of a sympathetic crowd that laughed at
his jokes and applauded his boasts while
Collins feebly tried to keep up like a
frantic School mom she tried to fact
check him on live TV but with Trump
that's like trying to put socks on an
octopus
Collins began by berating Trump for Jan
6. I wonder did Trump have to pull it
out
oh let me pull it out
so so
if you look at
on January 5th the day before I said
please support our Capitol Police at law
enforcement they are truly on the side
of our country stay peaceful stay
peaceful this was the day before and
this was in the form of Twitter now use
truth truth social I think it's far
superior
always the promoter and if you remember
he made a video right outside the Oval
Office and he didn't need a script
because he doesn't need scripts like the
person who's in there right now
and if you remember I made a video
right outside the Oval Office in the
Rose Garden and I'm very proud of that
video I didn't have a script I don't
need scripts like a certain person
that's in there
as for E Gene Carroll maybe he doesn't
know her
I don't know her I never met her I have
no idea who she is her dog
or her cat was named vagina
seeing it was her cat
[Laughter]
I mean it makes more sense
hey vagina where did you get the dead
mouse
but is that true and does it matter even
if you hate Trump you go you got to
admit you just don't get this level of
realness from any other candidate that's
what it boils down to Americans might
find Trump annoying untrue or obnoxious
but you know what you're getting and
it's firing on all cylinders fast
if people don't want to keep paying
twice as much for everything they just
want to feed their families preferably
using a gas stove they want to live
their lives without the intrusion of
these miserable Elites and Trump even
makes the debt ceiling hilarious
you once said that using the using the
debt ceiling is a negotiating wedge just
could not happen you you said that when
you were in the philosophy so why is it
different now that you're out of office
because now I'm not president
[Laughter]
can't argue with that
but also Trump gets the media in a way
no other candidate in American history
has which means he knows how to handle
the people who lie to us every day I
wish I could get him to talk to my cable
company
but the liberal response was as
predictable as it was idiotic AOC says
CNN should be ashamed of themselves for
losing control of the Town Hall A Daily
Beast writer says CNN failed journalism
and the American public
well The Daily Beast does no failed
journalism
everyone there is a failed journalist
listen to these jackasses no surprises
and yet it was just it was a disgraceful
uh performance I'm not going to pretend
like it was easy for me to see the
former president get this forum tonight
to lie to the American people over and
over and over again I was wondering when
he was going to be fact checked in real
time I think we needed a Chiron This Is
A Lie This Is A Lie This Is A Lie this
is a lie what I didn't know was that the
audience would be filled with his cult
I would like to know if CNN was passing
out Kool-Aid before the event started
you know usually to hear such inspired
criticism you have to watch an episode
of Dancing With the Stars
so they're surprised it's contentious
they're outraged he answered their
questions they're offended that he
wouldn't back down how stupid are these
people it's exactly what everyone would
expect it's as if the media has never
heard of trump before it's like they'd
be surprised if he ate pasta with his
hands or bragged about his penis at a
funeral
that's how in sync they are with Biden
now they have short-term memory loss
it's like they'd be surprised to find
out the buildings were named after Trump
and not the other way around they're
just a Pareto morons then there's this
following the town of town hall CNN
interviewed the audience
does it bother you that he keeps talking
about 2020 and not 2024. how do you feel
about those lies so I feel like part of
it's also the media narrative as you
guys asked him the first question at the
Town Hall about the 2020 election rather
than current stuff so don't you think
you could say it's time for me to start
talking about 2024 and not lies that
aren't true couldn't the media ask him a
question about 2024 well there were
questions but you're right that was the
first thing
perfect the media complains that Trump
talks about the past after they ask him
about the past that's like asking a
shark to leave you alone while you cover
your naked body with barbecue sauce even
CNN reported on how messed up CNN is
noting that their Network boss is facing
a fury of criticism within the company
but maybe that outrage is meant to cover
their tracks for having Trump on so did
this town hall help Trump for 2024
didn't hurt hell at least Trump knows
where he's going compared to this fella
thank you
[Music]
can you imagine this confused fossil on
stage for an hour getting peppered with
gotcha questions from a hostile
interrogator it wouldn't be a town hall
it would be a town hanging but with
Donald Trump when he enters the Lion's
Den it's the lion that gets nervous
[Applause]
she's our third favorite Molly after
Ringwald and the drug
editor chief of the Federalist Molly
Hemingway
to do this show he needed a permission
slip from his parents oh said the guy
Benson show Guy Benson
she's so skinny kids from third world
countries send her food whose
contributor cat tip
[Applause]
hot air balloons have him on a no-fly
list my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
[Applause]
guy always a pleasure to see you and I
mean that
um this time uh you were I was surprised
to see you in the Green Room openly
weeping about how great you thought
Trump did you were basically saying oh
my God thank God he's back yeah I think
you it was amazing you know I didn't
expect that from you
because I didn't do that but that's fine
it's a good story
um I'm so confused by the cat name joke
maybe you can explain that to me at some
point although he's like I don't know
her at all but I know her cat's name
okay
um coming from a guy named guy there is
something Fair hit uh there is something
sort of delicious about CNN having their
best rated show in recent memory which
is like an average night for the five
but for them it's really good and they
are tearing themselves apart for it
right that is wild to see and their own
like correspondence are trashing their
own network for having this forum with
the man who is the leading candidate for
president of a major party like what are
they supposed to do not ask questions of
a candidate blackball him completely
like we can't normalize him I have
issues with Trump he was President of
the United States He is normalized
whether you like it or not he's running
for the office again maybe you don't
want to have a like a Thunderdome of his
fans cheering him on putting Caitlin
Collins on Island out there yes but you
know what do they want to do it's a it's
supposedly a News Network yeah no you're
absolutely right the thing is I think
and this is my conspiracy theory of
Molly that all of this complaining from
within the house of CNN is designed to
so that they could do this it's like
look like that's their cover what do you
make of that conspiracy I don't know I
mean they are so desperate because they
have such horrific ratings that they I
thought it was kind of interesting that
they did this but seeing Jake Tapper
near tears after it was an extra special
delight in addition to getting to see
this to see what happened there but this
is not just the former president this is
the like Far and Away top candidate for
the next Republican nomination the idea
like the media meltdown over this means
that they don't really trust the
American people like ask him questions
get the answers trust the American
people to make the decision but they
don't they they basically handled
everything by silencing him for the last
few years and it actually
counter-intuitively made it all that
more refreshing yeah to see him you're
like not sick of hearing him for the
last few years so it was like wow I
forgot this was great yeah it's actually
it's actually you kind of missed him
because you like if you saw remember he
he could be pretty tiresome I don't know
if you remember that guy you're only 12.
but uh what was amazing about CNN before
I go to see you then didn't have just
one big panel they had two big panels
it's like let's get double the panel to
trash Trump and then they had one guy
there I think was Byron Donald's and
this other dude we don't know but anyway
it was hilarious cat what did you make
of this
I feel like it's exactly what anybody
could have expected and exactly what
we've seen a lot before every time
Trump's on TV which is why I thought
just all of these reactions were just
all extremely dramatic I think saying
you know this is the end of the country
I don't think so or even like Chris
slick said America was very well served
by this it's like no it was about
ratings yes but that's what people do
all the time but I think I'm going to
start taking it up for myself yeah
people are like why like cat why did you
do that which I get asked a lot I'm just
gonna say because I love my country
that's great that is good yeah why are
you so mad at me because I love my
country
saying I'm upset or because oh I wanted
ratings or I wanted attention I I feel
like everyone employs it so why can't I
you know what he had a great answer on
Ukraine and they and the media basically
said he was soft on Russia because he
refused to commit on who should win and
he was
holding himself to the metric of the
body count we gave a presidential answer
yeah he wants to stop killing doesn't
care he doesn't see Russians die he
wants to see ukrainians die yeah that's
a presidential answer but
two two things the timing of it uh
wasn't great because it got it changed
the news narrative we're not talking
about Hunter and stuff today yeah that's
true we're not talking about the Biden
corruption so that was one reason uh
that uh I wish it would have been more
spaced out because they're going to try
to use this and to your point
one thousand percent there was a meeting
where they will publicly bash it yes
and bring him on because that will keep
it going they need him so and the
the moderator I'm not sure what was
being moderated other than uh his
responses
is it's it's her turn now but she has to
be careful because Acosta and the other
ones they all got books out of it and
they became part of the story and I
always say whenever a so-called
journalist or opinion piece or whatever
it is you want to be when you become
part of the story you your time is done
it's only a matter of time before people
move on and they won't take you
seriously anymore that's why where's
Acosta yeah where's the whole group have
to has been fired because they were the
story yeah so now they're trying to be
the story and but this time they think
they're clever with having everybody
bash CNN for doing it so they can keep
the new cycle going because everyone's
focused on Trump and you're trying to
give a break uh to Biden the good news
about that is all you have to do is wait
for Biden to speak and him get lost on a
three-foot Podium and then it kind of
switches back yes that's true well I'll
never become part of the story because I
don't you know I don't do
but don't be part of the story she's
part of the story now so get your book
and yeah I love the white pantsuit
though that's very nice hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else